[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys today we're going to show you a
couple photo shoot steps
and we're going to do it while we do a
real photo shoot and this is our
photographer nikita hi guys with over
six years of experience
[Music]
so let me quickly show you our female
model for today
[Music]
all right this is chantal hello
[Music]
and this is the rest of the team
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right guys let's start with the
first step
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get comfortable before the photo shoot
right
for sure most of the time when you're a
model when you do a photo shoot you
don't know the other model and this can
be a problem especially because they
might be young or they're inexperienced
they might be nervous and feel
uncomfortable getting close to someone
they probably don't know and especially
if it's in front of the camera so make
them comfortable before the photo shoot
strike up a conversation
make jokes and make them feel more
relaxed get them in a good mood
so if the other person is not relaxed
you can clearly see it on the photo and
that's not what you want
[Music]
[Applause]
another tip look at the side of their
eye
at some point you will have to look in
the other model's eyes and sometimes you
get this uncomfortable staring contest
and you get it while you wait for the
click of the camera so instead of
looking straight into their eyes just
look at the corner
here and you can even tell the other
person to do the same so both of you
will feel more comfortable
[Music]
unless you are a real couple fully in
love and then well just go at it
[Music]
so
another tip is not to think about doing
poses just do what you would normally do
just act natural basically be you
when you try to get nice photos if you
keep on just thinking about doing the
poses it's not gonna look natural
and you want to look natural
so just forget about the camera
[Music]
hold your hand as you normally would
look at her or him
at the ground
far away
put your arm around her
or just sit with them and talk
don't think pose just think look natural
[Music]
fit on the model like a glove
yeah because guys if one of you
serious and the other one just smiling
is not gonna work
if they walk and you just stand still
it's not gonna work
try to shoot as a team and not a solo
model so walk together
have the same facial expressions
and try to look in the same direction
[Music]
or
if they look at you you can look
anywhere but if they look somewhere else
look at them
or to the ground
or
look where they are looking
just don't look in the opposite
direction
[Music]
number five change your poses
don't do the same thing over and over
give the photographer more variety you
can do walking poses 45 degrees to the
left and 45 degrees to the right and
straight to the camera
and then you can do the same with
standing poses and with sitting poses as
well
[Music]
and then while you do it you can change
your hands
your head direction and
body direction as well and of course
your expressions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to the photographer
they know what looks good because they
see the photo from their angle
and believe me they will tell you when
you need to change your post
or hold it for a few shots if it looks
great
and if you're uncertain about something
just ask them
[Music]
the shortest person should always try to
be closer to the camera than the taller
person why
because if they are not they look even
shorter and the tall person even
taller
so just balance it out by standing
closer to the camera if you're short
this is especially important with
walking poses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number eight your hips should always be
closer to the other person if you're a
couple and you're doing standing poses
it's always better to stand closer to
the other model with your hips in their
direction rather than away from them
[Music]
and always remember very very important
respect the other model
yes don't put me in a position where i
have to kiss you and i feel
uncomfortable
never do something they're uncomfortable
with it's not right and if you do they
might not cooperate well for the rest of
the photo shoot
so
think before you just do something as
models we're always professional and
this is our job
[Applause]
another cool tip to remember is to do
talking poses it looks really good
especially if you can do it naturally
here's a few tips
show your hands pretending to explain
something
or show numbers or another form of
communication
open your mouth just a bit as if you're
about to say something
[Music]
and let your facial expressions join the
action
[Music]
[Music]
look at many examples of couple poses
and get inspired nothing beats your own
experience so go and practice
all right guys now remember no fake
poses
just be yourself keep it real be you
yeah we'll see you guys in the next
video cheers
bye